i
have decided to leave i'm going to leave
cody
sister wife star christine brown's
choice to leave her plural marriage to
cody will play out in the show's new
season
but ahead of the premiere she's
revealing the reason behind her decision
and it involves one of their kids
i've always said now i've been quoted
here for a long time i you've seen me
say on this show
nobody is a prisoner here if if this
isn't working for you
you know just i
and the problem for us is this is that
there's five of us very five different
thinking adults who are trying to raise
kids together have a family together and
we don't see eye to eye on all things
christine tells people it had to do with
a medical situation with her and cody's
daughter isabelle who has scoliosis
wearing the daytime brace is hard
um
because i look bigger
and i can't do as much she's a pretty
amazing resilient kid and this is super
hard on her
all right
you're good
give us a hug
and in september 2020 isabelle underwent
surgery to correct it while the mom of
six traveled with her for the procedure
cody opted out using the covet 19
pandemic as the reason to stay behind
we've had some misunderstandings because
of kovid
where
i mean
any relationship
okay
plural marriage put a little little more
pressure on a relationship
and although christine says she
understood it their daughter still has a
hard time with it to this day quote he
broke my little girl's heart i really
find it hard to stay with a guy who i
don't respect for christine cody's
absence was a wake-up call
she adds quote in the end i would have
preferred to have him there of course
because it's what isabel needed but i
didn't need him anymore i really like
living separate i like my own space i
like my own autonomy i feel like i like
me better now as and i just feel like
i've been able to
really like raise my kids how i want to
i really have more of an independence
after that situation with isabel
christine didn't announce she was
leaving her marriage of 25 years until
november 2021. while cameras rolled on
the new season of sister wives
you never tried to have really good
relationship with these other people
and that's the reason i'm pissed off
man just the knife in the kidneys over
all these years
sacrifices that i made
to love you
i agreed to be a sister wife but i
agreed to be an equal
wife yeah it's hard it's hard to watch
yourself it's really hard to watch
yourself so i just know that it's coming
up and i'm like and it's really
raw and open and we're super vulnerable
and just super honest and sometimes it's
just not really fun to watch yourself a
lot
so i kind of cringe a little bit when i
think that it's coming fans will also
see how her fellow sisters janelle mary
and robin react to the news i feel like
it's more of an inevitability coming
instead of a let's try to work this out
i felt like that christine was more than
a sister wife i felt like that she was a
friend for a lot of years
i'm not ready for christine to leave
hang on with me okay
i am
we have to rebuild the new season of
sister wives begins september 11th on
tlc
[Music]
you